around the world economies are crumbling
since the corona virus outbreak the
price of every vital commodity is fallen
we're seeing a lot of these markets hit
coronavirus has oil below $50 a barrel
US demand in China has dropped off
substantially you're impacted demand for
copper iron or even gold is going down
America's Department of Labor has
recorded the highest ever number of new
and employment claims in the past two
weeks just under 10 million government's
had modeled the impact of a pandemic on
their economies but when in no way
prepare the indication is that economic
activity has been sledge-hammered in the
course of a couple of points just how
deep is the crisis for the world economy
over the past two months the world's
biggest stock markets have turned red it
falls like that because investors
certainly have to recalculate the future
for the economy and the future of
corporate profits and adjust their
figures sharply downwards and then they
tend to sell assets which are the most
liquid often those are the big companies
in the S&P 500 the S&P 500 had its
quickest bear market decline in history
when the.com bubble burst in 2000 it
took almost two years for the S&P 500 to
drop by 49 percent the 2007 to 2009
financial crisis led to a fall of almost
60 percent in just over a year the
corona virus pandemic has already seen
the market fall by a third in just one
month
this class has been so quick because it
was such a shock in the financial crisis
there was actually quite a long lead-up
it was a good long 18 months of bad news
but this is genuinely a deus ex machina
a bolt from the blue
where investors and were just not
pricing in the risk of a pandemic and of
course governments have never in the
past imposed the kind of lockdown on a
global economy that they have this time
so this was not something people had in
their models in an effort to stop the
deadly virus businesses have been forced
to close and citizens isolated at home
on an unprecedented scale worldwide it's
caused a unique economic crisis the
impact of which will be greater on some
industries in particular the industries
which are hit hardest are those which
are related to the consumer so that's
retailing that's entertainment that's
hospitality both hotels and restaurants
many of which have simply been locked
down and many of these companies will
have high costs which they'll need to
keep meeting so certainly you have lots
of cost continuing and absolutely no
revenues which is the worst possible
outcome for these businesses but even if
a business isn't directly losing out
from people staying at home lockdowns
are having a devastating ripple effect
modern industry relies on goods and
materials crossing borders when they
can't production around the world is
endangered the coronavirus caused a
break in the biggest link in this vast
global supply chain the problem started
in China where the disease started
really to be seen in December and then
had a huge impact in January China is
the bedrock of the global supply chain
businesses started to look for
alternative suppliers but of course that
was a race to try and find the few that
had spare capacity
as the virus spread alternative
suppliers have become fewer and further
between it's going to take a very very
long time for them to rebuild their
supply chains and in the interim was
very little demand for finished products
a few companies are going to want to
resurrect that supply chain instantly
until they know that the economy has
settled down the true extent of the
damage to the world economy will only
start to become clear with the speed and
strength of its recovery the big
questions that economists are still
trying to grapple with is whether this
is what they call a v-shaped recession
or or a u-shaped position or an l-shaped
recession in a v-shape recession the
economy suffers a rapid fall but
rebounds very quickly as opposed to a
longer economic trough before recovery
or long term recession now the most
encouraging news we've had so far
is that in China which was the first
economy to be hit and the latest figures
suggest the most hopeful possibility
which is that this is a v-shaped
recession now if China can do that the
hope is that Europe and America can do
that later on when the lock downs are
lifted Europeans and Americans are also
being helped by unprecedented government
responses
330 billion pounds 2.2 trillion dollars
and urgently needed relief these
short-term protections might reduce the
damage the economy suffers but this
pandemic could last a long time so the
difficult calculation for governments is
trading off the lives of people who will
die from the coronavirus versus the
economic damage to the economy year-long
lock downs would cost America and the
eurozone perhaps 1/3 of their GDP models
looking at America suggest that ending
lock downs would lessen that damage but
would lead to around 1 million extra
deaths in the last 75 years since the
second world war we've seen nothing like
this governments have not reacted on the
scale so although it's terrible in a way
it shows our humanity that we want to
reduce the number of deaths so much that
we're willing to put up with all these
restrictions and well willing to accept
a big hit to economic activities I'm
Philip Coggan I'm reporting for The
Economist on the financial crisis that's
been created by the pandemic if you want
to read more click on the link opposite
and thank you for watching